hey it's ogen yeah we decided we're
gonna do another sidetrack doing one of
our little sidetrack shows first
Wednesday just watching everything
unfold a lot of this [ __ ] out he's gonna
make it I don't think I don't think
Hollywood's gonna and pull him through
it it'll come back but it won't be like
it was yeah I mean a lot of things will
be different is model just before we
started recording I was like cuz you
know we have the AMC the a-list
subscription and I had just got a email
like a few minutes ago that said that
they actually weren't gonna charge
people obviously because all the
theaters had to close you know for six
to 12 weeks and they're like we didn't
want to charge people like this they
couldn't go see movies which I thought
was pretty cool how much how much on a
better go just the way I was talking
about
it'll be like Netflix which is well like
I said app they've already kind of
Universal already did that some of the
other some of the other movie studios
might have done it to like Joe because
Universal came out first and they said
yeah they're showing like as a Friday
they're gonna be showing like the movies
that they have in theatres so you can
stream them as well yeah you have to pay
obviously but it's just like renting
yeah cuz it's gonna stay like that yeah
they're not gonna let you watch them for
free yeah oh yeah I don't know like it
might go back like I said they're still
like you know other kinds it alone it'll
it'll only go back to those theatres
that were really strong and really
strong yeah I bet you they won't reopen
weak theaters well yeah they probably
won't because yeah they would have the
star they were already struggling yeah
it's probably better I don't think
they're gonna go away entirely um you
know because we've gone to see movies
and they was full you know I mean so
people still do go yeah but um what's
what you got for us what do you want to
talk about like lots of different stuff
um I was gonna talk about I probably
mentioned this before but um you know I
designed board and card games which is
kind of like just a fun thing that I do
when I have free time
um I have like three first sale already
on the game crafter but what I was gonna
spend the rest of this month doing was I
have like a whole bunch of other ones I
have a whole bunch of other ones done
and I have like only like a couple more
that I want to do and
eventually I'm gonna like have like a
whole dedicated website with all the
different games on them that people can
cuz you guys are stuck at home anyway
Boswell plug these board game that's it
right no you can sit around here play
show it to him Jane well yeah like one
of them's back there's called three
sorrows which is kind of based on the
Dario Argento yeah and that's kind of
well it's kind of big and I don't wanna
I didn't want to disturb Dennis in front
of it it's kind of like one it's kind of
like mystery mansion but you know in the
sense that you kind of build the board
as you go you know what I mean like you
just put keep putting rooms on this
mansion yeah well I you know what I I
have so many projects and I love writing
and I love doing the show and I love
everything like that but if somebody
like held a gun to my head and said you
can only do one thing for the rest of
your life it would probably be doing
boarding card games thank you because
well because it kind of it not only has
you know the the aspect of you having to
come up with a story and coming up with
rules and coming up with characters and
stuff like that but it's like also has a
graphic design thing and I have like
this thing where I really really like
making a bunch of things with like a
similar theme that's like for some
reason that's why I like doing like book
design and I like doing that kind of
stuff
because it'll show one over there yeah
the one that I have this one is actually
these ones are just all kind of based on
giallo
movies but the other ones that I'm
working on are all different stuff
although they usually like gothic horror
type of theme like I have one that's an
Edgar Allen Poe trivia game I have one
that is based on it's called Villa
Diodati
Jojo about well this no this is I'm
talking about a different show they're
probably well I will admit it just let
me talk let me talk about and I had one
called
Villa Diodati which is about you know if
you guys know the Haunted summer
quote-unquote of 1816 where Mary Shelley
and Lord Byron and all them are like
together in Geneva and they she ended up
writing Frankenstein stuff so I have one
based on that I have like an ancient
Greek one that's called Gorgons lair
like about killing Medusa and also their
kind of stuff so this one
I think I've shown it probably on the
show before but this one is like kind of
based on a giallo type movie it's called
the Crimson drop on a Crystal Palace
yeah is a very Glos title see it's real
pretty and I'll tell you what a
picture's worth a thousand words
all right yeah show the back show the
back because it's got some yeah cards
and stuff on it and that one is just
like yeah it's upside down is it upside
down okay yeah it's basically this one
is a card game and it's basically like a
you solve a mystery it's kind of like
clue but you know it's not it's kind of
like clue crossed with like one of those
like party murder mystery games but the
mystery is different each time you know
I mean because some of those murder
mystery games like the tiny ones can
play um I think this one is it says on
the box I think doesn't it you don't
remember no well because all of them are
different they're out every time it's
either it's 2 to 6 or 2 to 8 that one is
but yeah so it's like you have these
kind of cards where it's kind of like
you know you get murdered you know this
kind of stuff there's like characters
there's uh
this is like a speculation card all this
other kind of stuff this is the action
deck and these I also have like these
are motive cards like mistaken identity
so the instructions easy to understand
yeah basically it kind of has a
component where you have somebody who is
the director and he basically he or she
basically comes up with they use the
cards and they come up with the who the
killer is what the weapon is what the
motive is and everyone else has to like
figure it out you know what I mean so it
has that kind of thing to it um and I
also did one this one is called again
like I said I love coming up with giallo
names this one is called the cursive
names of nightmares and this one is just
like a card game I don't know if you
guys have ever heard of schmoovy which
is kind of like a popular card game
where it comes up with like all these
wacky you know
like a character like a nun and he and
she's like doing this and that and you
have to like come up with a movie pitch
and everybody comes up with a movie
pitch about this like crazy situation or
plot or whatever and then everybody like
judges like which one's the best one so
this one's kind of like that but you
have to come up it's like all the cards
have like giallo esque
movie title words on them um you know
like butterfly and velvet and things
like that so you have to like you get
cards and you come up with a name and
then you have to come up with a pitch
for a movie that goes along with it and
then like the best one wins okay so I
have that one and this one also has this
one also has an expansion pack that's
called gore galore which if you want to
get super bloody these are like more
bloody words crimson drop also has an
expansion pack if you want to make the
mistery harder because this has extra
characters extra locations and stuff
like that that you can add to the decks
they all look the same so you can do
that so are there other games like this
I mean like is this a genre of game like
if something like so another game would
they like this one um probably like I
said crimson drop is kind of like clue
but also like a murder mystery like a
party murder mystery okay but different
each time
because because it has a director like a
dungeon master essentially that comes up
with the mystery using the cards saying
this is what the motive is and all this
other kind of stuff and other people
have to figure it out I'm working on
another one which will be a similar kind
of thing I'm still working on the
mechanics of it but like I said they're
not all gonna be giallo based like I
started doing them like that but then I
had like all these other ideas for doing
different ones I have most like I said I
have a Greek one I have like the UM you
know the the Mary Shelley one I have an
Edgar Allan Poe one and I also have like
some cool you know play just regular
playing card decks but I made like a
Edgar Allan Poe playing card deck that
has like different suits like it has a
tell-tale heart and like a raven and
stuff like that instead of you know the
the normal suits so I did something like
that like I have an Egyptian one like an
ancient Egyptian one an ancient Greek
one stuff like that so hopefully I'm
trying to finish enough games by the end
of this
month that eventually you know by the
end of the year I want to have like a
dedicated website out that just has all
of them on there so can you get them now
these ones are on the game crafter like
the game crafter calm /g Allah games or
something like that i usually i have the
link usually in the what to call it
subscription video yes so i so I have
those three available right now like I
said it's most of them are designed but
what you have to do is when you upload
them to the game crafter you have to
order a copy for yourself like to proof
it before they let you put it on sale so
even though I have like a bunch of done
I'm trying to get a bunch done and then
I'm just gonna slowly like order them
and make sure they're alright and
everything like that so but yeah that's
something that I've been working on I'm
trying to get most of the games done in
March because starting April 1st I want
to start working on faceless villain
millenium or whatever it is them yeah
and of calling it the fourth one right
that'll be the fourth one it's great
it'll be you know a similar thing it'll
be twenty years it'll be like from 2000
to 2009 teen it's like unsolved crimes
yes I'm talking about it when we do our
walks yeah what what three money you
sometimes walk six miles a day yeah cuz
I almost always get up and do three
miles before you go yeah we always talk
about the cases that end up in a book
yeah it's gonna be good I think it's
gonna be good and yeah so I'm kind of
hoping I have it scheduled to start
writing like working on it April first
I'm hoping to get like a chapter done
every week which is not crazy because
that's about what I was doing before and
then hopefully have it out it should be
out there yeah it's gonna have a lot of
them that are still ongoing yeah cuz
this one's gonna be like recently yeah
reason I mean you know I mean so we've
built up to it so I'd imagine you're
imagine the the customers we've had a
lot of good repeat customers on that
series they're gonna be waiting for this
one that's what I think more than one
person is like asked me if I was gonna
do it because they said well now it's
2020 so it's like you have another 20
year period that in the past that you
didn't write about we plan that [ __ ] too
I didn't I didn't but each other
we planned well actually when it started
when you started to get done with the
with the last one we started talking
about it yeah and so it was
one of the things cuz I said well I'm
either going to I have like a bunch of
different possibilities I was like
sitting there going well okay I'm either
gonna do like creepiest disappearances
of the 20th century look another trilogy
or I was gonna do like just one case
like I was gonna pick like maybe a local
case that a lot of people didn't know
about and just delve into one case and
do that right there you have a claim to
fame case yeah something that nobody
else has done right and you know I might
still do that but you know and we've got
lock of local law enforcement in other
places that me know we can get access to
an interview people yeah I think so I
think I can get you that's well yeah
that's what I figured
so but then like I had so many people
ask you know aren't you get are you
gonna do a faceless Bell on for like
because the 20 year period just is up
and like now you could do like recent
cases for 21st century so I figured
that'd be the next one and then oh yeah
reassess like what I want to do just cuz
so many people asked me if I was gonna
do that one um another thing I wanted to
shout out speaking of when I was talking
about book design before and I don't
know we I'm sure we probably mentioned
this because this is a while back that I
did this
if you guys need if any of you guys are
vegans or interested in vegan food and
need some recipes and stuff like that
this book right here done by our friend
and I actually designed this whole book
I did the cover I did all the inside I
did all that stuff it took forever this
is the vegan black metal chef and this
is his yeah cookbook and yeah we're
friends with Brian yeah he's he's
seriously one of the nicest most awesome
dudes ever he would have California I
think he's moving back though come back
um that's what I heard like I think I
saw on his Facebook or Instagram
come on ABC nightly news [ __ ] like
that's [ __ ] sad like what it looks
Brian doing on there I'd like something
out of kiss making damn vegan he's
hilarious and if you guys I don't know
like I I haven't seen like any of his
videos lately but it's like if you
haven't seen any of his videos like
vegan black metal chef they are
hilarious
yeah and like a lot of these recipes are
really good but yeah see he's got like
all them he took all the photographs of
the food yeah he's a real artist and
he's in a band he's a bass player a
guitar player
I've never accidentally see one of his
him playing with one of those bands yeah
I think he was in three oh yeah one is
in several yeah well pretty much
everybody we know usually more than one
yes I'm like wait a minute which you're
in those three bands and it's like these
other whether they're thoughts or
thoughts or cam girls or porn stars yeah
like pretty much everybody we know yeah
into something like that do something
like that even if they have like a
normal job because a lot of them do you
have normal jobs to you and then like a
lot of them do that all that kind of
stuff on the side yeah another thing to
you or the only honest one I don't know
I wouldn't say there's no scam girls
look crystal said you guys are though
you guys just regular honest people
Crystal's this girl it works it
she plays storm and a bunch of other
characters Universal Studios and she's
just this actress model that girl tall
black girl blonde hair her bald-headed
but always wearing some kind of a wig
and she she accused us of being like the
only honest ones well with the most
normal yeah I think that was funny
yeah she's at she's awesome and her um
her husband who's a myth spider yeah
he's um real good artist he's a really
good artist and actually for a time I
don't know because remember when that
that comment that really big comic book
store be the name of that store that
that friend of yours owns yeah Kimber
what he calls it gods and monsters gods
and monsters yes he does professional
murals yeah the dude can paint [ __ ]
murals there yeah he had all the
painted by somebody museum or it looks
like comic book art or just whatever he
can do anything
yeah with awesome [ __ ] great might
take a couple months but [ __ ] man the
Sistine Chapel level [ __ ] better yeah
better looks like a photograph some of
that stuff yeah it's really it's really
good but yeah we know we know like a lot
of talented people you're right we do um
another thing I wanted to mention to you
and I'm very excited about this and this
is what this is pretty much the only
reason that I hope like the world's not
edited that everything gets not Annie I
know I'm just making it you know and I
hope that things get back to normal
before autumn yeah because I am gonna go
to Atlanta yeah you know see her sister
NC Nikki yeah my sister lives in Atlanta
yeah and she and I didn't know he was
playing up there because he never ever
ever comes to Florida because he
probably liked that state which you know
I can't blame them whatever well the
thing about Florida it's that if they
don't think they're gonna get enough
people it's just it's too far down like
the you know what I mean it out of the
way it's out of the way cuz it's like to
hit all the major cities you have to
Orlando you have to go all the way
[ __ ] down to Miami which is another
like four or five hours then you have to
come all the way back up and it's like
for a lot of bands it's like not really
worth it you know what I mean because
it's just like takes so long to get it
because the state is like so long like
you get to the bottom and they get back
to the top and the cities are kind of
far apart but so he's so my sister like
contacted me the other day and she's
like hey do you want me to get you a
ticket and I was like yeah it's like so
it's like October 3rd I think yeah she's
seen him before but I never got to like
I had tickets to see him at [ __ ]
Lollapalooza like back in 1994 he was
gonna yeah he was gonna play at
Lollapalooza in [ __ ] DeLand like at
the Volusia County Fairgrounds which was
only like 20 minutes from my house back
then yeah and I was super excited I want
to see l7 and some of the other bands
too but I was really got all about yeah
I was really really excited about Nick
Cave like especially yeah and then the
morning of of the show there had been
like a apocalyptic rainstorm like the
day before because
Florida and the [ __ ] stage sunk in the
mud huh so they had to cancel it the
morning and I'm still pissed about it
and they never like and they never I
mean I got my money back but they never
they just said [ __ ] it [ __ ] right cuz
you know no but yes October 3rd I'm kind
of planning on driving up there and
hanging out with my sister and going to
see Nick Cave and I'm yes I'm super but
it's not the end of the world people
said we pitch had some knots on budget I
bet some people in the comments sections
come up with this crazy [ __ ] you don't I
mean that damn animals were sacrificed
on [ __ ] Holland when all this [ __ ] no
no it's just that was like it's like
it's like I said before what remember
when this [ __ ] first came out I said
this is either some kind of a bioweapon
that got out or some kind of a vaccine
they were working on the guy something
it wasn't normal
I could just tell by the way Chyna acted
once it figured out what it was they
knew what it was but we're gonna see the
numbers when it comes here I don't think
we're gonna his back gonna get hit as
bad as China but like I said I was just
kind of like yeah I think yeah we're
just they're just gonna try to slow the
spread of it so so so everybody doesn't
get sick at once in which it does seem
like most people are being pretty cool
about it yeah you know what I mean and
they're they're they're gonna do all
kinds of measures they're gonna hand out
checks to everybody and try to keep the
economy propped up for a couple months I
mean you know it's funny there's gonna
come a point where they're gonna have to
get because okay they're already broke
the only time I well remember that
lasted a bank stimulus and they gave all
the money to the banks and it just
vanished they're like wait you could
have given each person like $20,000 yeah
and and that would have rejuvenated the
economy well yeah because poor people am
i poor people have to buy it the
infrastructure is and Kitty Lee
infrastructures for the manufacturing
infrastructure is gonna be intact
they're still making food they're still
making stuff that's what I mean that's
why I'm like they're gonna be in there
working it's just the people people who
had jobs who were buying [ __ ] have to
start getting money to keep them you
know to keep those industries afloat you
got to keep the buyers stocked with
money well yeah this is a change this is
gonna change a lot of the economy
in the way certain things runs in terms
of industries is gonna change it I think
pretty much forever because now's the
time where you could actually make
improvements well yeah well everybody's
kind of yeah why it's like it's like
this it's like a reset you can't you
can't fix an engine while it's running
yeah you got you can only rebuild an
engine if you stop the engine to take it
apart and you can kind of do that now
that's what I was saying yeah yeah
because everyone's just kind of like
they're just sitting around it
why restart this business here it wasn't
doing well in enon in the old format
let's change it a lot of shit's gonna be
online this is gonna be the beginning of
like an online world yeah well I mean
like I said it was going like that it's
going that way anyway I'll probably just
move yeah it's gonna move it ahead 10
years how much on a bet
yeah probably well which like I said it
sucks now but that it might turn out
better he'll turn out because it kind of
hoping it's more efficient sucks old
people die but you know what I mean it's
more efficient we could we couldn't you
couldn't stop that over stopping that
yeah stop in the economy or slowing the
economy is slowing and those deaths yeah
preventing a lot of them you know if you
just let it run wild it would be worse
yeah so although people are still
running around in grocery stores like
idiots well you well you're you have to
shop you have to get supplies I'm sure
everybody's got supplies by now well the
thing is is that this might go on first
this might go on for three or four weeks
what they're gonna do is they've got
this [ __ ] [ __ ] in little quadrants
this is how I would do it so this is
probably how they're gonna do it because
I know how militaries and governments
think you know it worked for working for
them I bet you they can shut off roads
and quarantine certain areas just at the
drop of a hat now that's what they're
saying well yeah I think they have plans
rise for that kind of what they're gonna
do is is they're gonna wait two weeks
and in two weeks they'll see the date of
the numbers of how many people are sick
and where and then they're gonna shut
those hotspots down the other places
where it isn't that bad they're gonna
kind of do some containment then but
then just let that run yeah that's what
they're gonna do yeah they don't care if
you get sick they just don't want
everybody getting sick at once right
that's it
so in this more rural areas this they're
not gonna be quarantined well yeah
because why would they snot danson are
apart any
right well that's where a lot of this
shit's being made you grow food out in
that area yeah you know and like I said
it throw any factories in cities like
for a while but everything's gonna be I
feel like I'll get a lot done you know
yeah but yeah oh when I was talking
about Nick Cave before I wanted to say I
just totally I'm getting Nick a I do
he's my favorite skinny the jockey she
loves I like shoes all right yeah he's
red and I like some of his music yeah
some is too gospel II for man well it
depends on the on the era yeah I tend
more toward his earlier stuff like I
really I love the birthday party and
like I love like his first like probably
I've until like the early to mid-90s
after that like I like all of it but you
know once he started getting like this
stuff started getting a little bit
slower and stuff but he does have like
Grindr man and like all these kind of
which is kind of like his yeah ugly like
dirty blues kind of you know side
project which is awesome but I just read
[ __ ] I just found I found this yesterday
just randomly on Amazon I was just like
I had bought some stuff on Amazon like a
few weeks ago and I needed something
else that cost like 10 bucks like so I
could get free shipping so I'm just like
looking for random [ __ ] and I just found
this thing this is so cool and I haven't
read it yet but it's uh it's called
mercy on me and apparently it's like
it's kind of like a biography but also
like a fictionalized biography that has
like some of the like stuff from his
songs and everything and yo it's like
it's a graphic novel that's like about
Nick Cave and some of its like true and
some of its just kind of like made up so
but it looks really cool and I'm like
man I gotta have that because I have a
bunch of his other precise King ink
which is all his you know essays and
lyrics and stuff and I have like a bunch
of different biographies of and the book
fish in a barrel which is like all
photographs of them on tour and all this
other kind of stuff so like I said I'm
really jazzed about getting to see him
because I never got to and it's like
he's at least like in his 60s out I was
like if he drops dead without me being
able to see him live and be really
really mad
you know coz I've seen pretty much
everybody else I wanted to see ever
except Tori and Rin I never got to see
Jerry Duran yeah although I would have
ideally I would go see them now if it
wasn't like 400 bajillion dollars
because I think the last time they came
through here was really expensive some
and ran shows are very kind of
mainstream I would have liked I would
have more preferred to see them like
back in back in 85 or something like on
that big [ __ ] tour they did remember
that [ __ ] because I used to have my
VHS arena like the album that came out I
think that came out at 85 and um the
tour that went along with it and there
was like a movie you know that they made
while on the road and I must have
watched that like 40,000 times what is a
teenager so I would have liked to have
seen that tour but you know I need to
invent a time machine to do that so um
do you have anything else no I don't
know instead I gotta go make from this
damn Chinese food in a bit your may
actually no I don't do that now I just
got it in there marinate pork job I was
gonna say you know he made and it was
only were it's about four o'clock in the
afternoon we're recording this now he
made like it was really brunch I guess
cuz it was kind of like 11:00 or 11:30
we haven't done this in a long time
though he made like eggs bacon pancakes
like the whole deal and I was like oh
well it's like it was delicious but I'm
like well that's my food for the day
cook those pancakes and that bacon
grease - I know you did and so it's like
as soon as I was like a little bacon
grease yes indeed see I think that deep
down you want me to be fat no because I
told because you seemed kind of bad cuz
you cuz you guys is like oh that wasn't
that breakfast really good I'm like yeah
it was really good but I can't eat
anything else for the rest of the thing
that I I didn't think about it that way
my I have the only thing they had the
only thing that really had two calories
were the pancakes and the syrup yeah you
know I mean eggs and bacon they're not
that bad for you that's protein well
eggs eggs are really good for but I have
like I have probably the world's slowest
metabolism you know what I mean it's
like people that you know people that
are all kind of like oh I just smell a
cupcake and I gained five pounds yeah
that's me I age in dog years I don't get
well yeah and it's like so you can you
can eat a lot more than me it's like
seriously if I eat if we go to like I'm
lifted she
Blamey well no it's it's not so much
that it's it's not so much weight gain
that I'm talking about it's that you can
eat a lot more like if I eat a lot in
one sitting I will throw up you know I
just start feeling start feeling really
sick
no I could eat I know and I've seen it
it's like we'll go to like the you know
the Chinese buffet or something like
that
he'll eat like - that's it he'll eat
like four piled high a place and I'll go
back and get sushi and that'll give him
like where are you putting that like I
am one and a half plates and I'm like oh
no and then to be honest after all that
I had room for more yeah
I'd eat I'd eat two or three big old
piled up plates of that damn boiled
shrimp I know I've seen you do it and
like six cups of the damn six cocktail
saw you like six of those no go get some
sushi
yeah beef yeah but there's no I'm not
eating any carbohydrates Harley
yeah we don't eat how did you see pros
that's kind of the nice thing about cuz
there's one there's one that's not far
from us called koi wan and it's like
this massive buffet yeah and yeah what
regret seeing me full up there like we
need all the strength he's gonna eat all
the shrimp well because I eat all the
shrimp - yeah like between menu but um I
try it yeah I try to stick to seafood
like I love noodles and stuff but I try
not to eat no noodles no rice no nothing
like that it's like I'll just eat you
shrimp if they have any fish like pepper
steak we cheat though I mean those we do
those crab rangoon man I had one Devon
those who are like I got one and then
those pot stickers I'd wanted - this
pasta like I like them but I'll just I'm
gonna have one you know what I mean make
me want to go to koi one in the middle
gate spot like man the [ __ ] apocalypse
in the apocalypse that I'm thinking
about who I want
it's probably close to us I don't see
how you could be hungry after all that I
mean I know we ate breakfast like a lot
of hours ago
cycle I'm still sitting there cycle of
my stomach I don't know I just can't I
can't control it
I can control it's just that I can't
control the desire for it yeah when I
said when I start talking about it I'm
going like oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah let's see let's eat all
of ya
I understand I try to do that to you but
it's like I just I can't get away with
it I didn't ever get off though you know
I could never get away with it but you
got me thinking about Chinese food yeah
but what it's I was making some but I
was now I'm thinkin bout potstickers
yeah Branca well that well the thing
about it though is that one good thing
about really only like if I eat a big
meal that's all eat all day and
sometimes like I'll wait until like
lunch the next day to eat so it'll be
like a long fast but um one thing about
that that's good is that I like to make
sure that if I'm gonna eat something
then it's something that's really good
and something I really want you know
what I mean like I'm not just gonna
waste calories on like just some crabs
that I don't really and I'm just like oh
that's okay you guys don't know it all
that Chinese food that I can cook it
it's just it's you can cook everything
made out achieve [ __ ] you can cook it it
looks exotic but it's not exotic like
that mustard this is powdered mustard
water well yeah but they don't have that
a quite one they have the [ __ ] cheap
[ __ ] that's in the damn plastic I only
like Doug's laughs anyway yeah duck
sauce that's just um apricot jam yeah I
know brown sugar and a little bit of
vinegar yeah that's good but yeah well
yeah you cooked Chinese good you can
cook Thai food Indian food problem I
like your Indian food the best although
you can you can make pretty much
anything yeah garyun paprikash yeah yeah
my Poppa Koster [ __ ] [ __ ] you up that
is that's one of my favorite things I
gotta go get that dude we don't make it
too much cuz it's fattening sour cream
it's all sour cream of society potatoes
you can do potatoes or you can do
noodles but those of which are carbs so
which is not good it's really really
sure money - it wouldn't mind making
some of those damn those little polish
things it's like yeah yeah yeah it's
Hiroki froggies yeah pierogies we
haven't made those in a long time that's
been like years since the last time you
made those actually am i making some
brazilian food like Koshien yeah that's
what I was just gonna say
yeah you better a chicken and vegetable
spicy with with a damn dough around it
and then you deep-fry any deep-fried
shape like a like a teardrop it kinda
like a fat yeah
mean little thigh doesn't look like a
chicken thigh yeah it's got like
shredded chicken inside and it's like
yes and stuff those are really really
good yeah bust days yeah what you're
like this like the Chinese thing but you
know yeah man so much good food make me
fat talk about it that's what I mean
it's like I can I shake it off I can
shake it off getting it going to food
erotica yeah well you know it does
happen yeah I was thinking about like
Brazilian what's called ssagaji news
which is little thing little Soltys
they're like hors d'oeuvres and that is
nothing called called palmito which is
like a little beady pie like a big
around as a silver dollar and about that
high it's with spiced hearts of palm in
it man that's just so good it's like a
pie with hearts of palm a little bit of
tomato in it and and garlic it's good
yes you put a little bit of egg white on
top so it has a little bit of glaze make
it shiny yes yeah I know you can see you
can see us gaining weight by the moment
all right we better go before we before
we gain any more we're just gonna go
right off that's crazy I got I gotta get
back on YouTube or something or I'll
start eating it's gonna get in there eat
all the protein bars and the ramen not a
need Romani anymore yeah we have so much
like every now and then I'll eat some
too much carbs it is I was horrified to
find out how many calories are just in
like one packet cuz it seems like
nothing it just seems like I see what is
it's like 700,000 calories in disguise
no no my family all my calories for the
day [ __ ] that and there's no nutritional
value in and not really there's no
protein in it there's hardly any fat in
it I mean it's just filler they're good
to have fun yeah because you can put
stuff in there like I usually throw them
in with like other types of soup or you
can like put boiled eggs in there that
is good that kind of stuff but yeah a
Caucasian can't get any damn nutrition
out and do
I really do think the Japanese have
certain genetics that allow them to get
more out of noodles and rice maybe
because they're because it does they eat
them more of them just because they I
think they just evolved as rice farmers
for thousands of years they just write
that fat yeah it just makes us fat we
don't gain thing out of it yeah but the
thing is you know I think flour makes
them fat interests because you know when
they don't use it they don't use the
seat to the extent that we Europeans
your people of European heritage grew up
eating bread yeah that was our version
of a bowl of rice was amazing that mega
mega fat but I think I'm gonna make send
even fatter and then we've had some I
can eat it not gain weight yeah yeah I
don't haven't noticed it nothing like
pasta yeah it seems worse worse yeah I
mean breads not too bad depending on
what kind of bread you get like I like
to get those like half color like the
thinner slices so that you know each
slice is only like 70 calories which
isn't that big and I was in Brazil used
to get a whole loaf of damn fresh-baked
bread from the bakery to start eating it
yeah but then again I was a teenager so
you could eat anything when you're a
teenager and especially teenage dudes
yeah they can just dog years yeah you're
you're aging in dog years because I've
seen I knew some guys growing up like
teenage guys that were just kind of like
they they ate an unbelievable amount of
food and were thin and they're eating
sugar too there yeah it was it was all
like crap always like all junk food yeah
like a shot where he and candy and pizza
and yeah not gaining a pound
yeah it's just because like wait
metabolisms running age their
metabolisms running in a way to process
somehow they're turned into energy yeah
I guess yeah I don't know even though
all they're doing is sitting around on
the couch playing video games yeah where
the calories are getting bird well I
think they jerk it off a lot of their
metabolism cut yeah you when you when
you're a young guy your metabolism kind
of runs hard to begin with yeah I guess
you're kind of transforming you know and
and you're under a transformer yeah you
can't transform anything you got a high
testosterone count so that's like a
performance-enhancing drug yeah so you
can just run harder yeah and that's just
it was just your body just to wipe it
out you're in insulin we'll just come
and take all that sugar out yeah you're
the incident response
my grandma used to say he's got a hollow
leg yeah that's what she used to say
when I start getting in their 20s you
start getting fun oh yeah these are
getting fat that is up with you huh yeah
all right so you want to go yeah let's
go he's gotta go before he's hurt so
yeah go right stuff okay we'll talk to
you guys again soon